this is where I came out of speedforce
what is then you came out Navy City no I
ran there after I remember now this is
where I came out this is where the
portal opened and a wave of dark matter
washed out with you I can only imagine
how many metahumans you created hey
everybody we may have found out who the
final bus meta is on the flash with a
bit of a twist but there's a bunch of DC
TV stuff happening so I'll remind
everybody about the schedule there's
also one of the classic actors from the
Superman movies that's going to be
coming on one of the TV shows really
soon too
so blow ursa a kiss come forward your
general wishes to speak I am General Zod
like I said all the shows are coming
back this week so if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's also a new
round of that blasts ring giveaway but
the big deal about this supposed final
bus meta is is that cecile is supposed
to get powers via her pregnancy so it
implies some really weird stuff is
happening and it's all probably part of
the thinker's plan so the people at the
CW released episode descriptions for the
next couple of episodes in an episode 12
it's like the Honey I Shrunk the Kids
episode where a couple of characters get
shrunk down but here I'll just read the
description this is for episode 12 it's
The Incredible Shrinking Men it says a
meta who can shrink anything he touches
battles team flash Cisco and Ralph get
caught in the crossfire enter shrunk to
miniature versions of themselves
Cecille realizes her pregnancy has
caused her to have temporary powers and
discovers she can hear other people's
thoughts which unnerved Joe meanwhile
Barry meets someone with a mysterious
connection to Henry Allen now that's
also a really big deal to like someone
mysterious that knows his father or has
some special connection to him just
shows up that might have something to do
with the mysterious caterer at Barry's
wedding which wasn't my reason for
making the video but when you read that
like who's somebody from Barry's past
that knows his father but Barry doesn't
know is actually a pretty big deal but
obviously on the surface level cecile
just getting magic powers because of her
pregnancy implies that the baby is a
meta
there's not some sort of other villain
of the week explanation for it because
why would you get temporary powers from
a pregnancy if the powers didn't have
something to do with the growing fetus
the obvious question to ask is as where
was she exactly when Barry came out of
the speedforce because even though they
detected 12 heat signatures on that bus
it's always possible that she was just
in the vicinity and caught some extra
dark matter so there are ways that she
could have been hit by that blast wave
without being on the bus because
otherwise you had to have some crazy
explanation because you could always get
powers by using some special technology
but they say that it's directly because
of the pregnancy that she gets these
psychic powers and even if they only use
it for comedy there are some serious
ramifications like wait a minute
if the baby is giving you powers then
how did the baby get powers in the first
place what's going on here poor Joe
can't catch a break first he has to
raise Barry and iris they go through
that whole ordeal then he has to learn
about a son that he never knew that he
had who also gets powers and he has to
deal with that too now he has a third
child that's potentially another
metahuman now a lot of people are taking
this potential metahuman baby and saying
oh that means that he's Daniel West
that's not what that means it just means
that there's some crazy reason that the
baby in the pregnancy are giving Cecile
powers it doesn't automatically confirm
that they're gonna do the Daniel West
reverse-flash you really can't say
confirmed until they say the baby's name
is going to be Daniel and I have a
feeling that they're gonna save the
baby's name to way way later in the
season unless they're doing some crazy
Scarlet Witch explanation where she's
not really pregnant and it's just some
trick of the thinker it just feels like
every weird thing that's happening this
season every crazy twist is part of the
plan that the thinker enacted at the
beginning like the whole reason that
Barry came out of the Speed Force was
because he wanted to create the 12
metahumans the reason why he wanted to
create the 12 metahumans was because of
his plan to enlighten the human race
because he probably needs some of them
to distract the flash and he needs some
of their abilities to spread whatever
plan that he has around the entire globe
I don't understand
your plan revolves around this don't as
lustreless as Rebecca is she may be the
most formidable of them all and why
don't we get her now the capricious
nature of the powers warrants for so
just remember that even though they've
been using the bus metas as villains of
the week they all work together as this
giant team and we don't know what
exactly they're going to be doing like
right now all the bus metas are really
just MacGuffin it's like oh you know
there's a film that we need to take down
he's doing crazy things but the thinker
didn't create them just to create havoc
for Team flash they're actually gonna
make sense all together at the same time
by the end of the season but usually
they wait till like episode 15 1617
before revealing what some of those
plans are but again back to the wedding
caterer mysterious Henry Allen figure
that Barry runs into that might have
something to do with her character
because she said that she had filmed her
second appearance before the break
they'd already started filming episode
14 so what might happen is is this Henry
Allen teaser plot might have something
to do with their two-part episode but
because this is until episode 12 I don't
think that we're gonna get any kind of
teaser for this for at least a couple
weeks but let me know in the comments
what do you think is going on with the
seals baby do you think that it was one
of the metahumans that was created when
Barry came out of the Speed Force even
if she wasn't on the bus but in related
news if you guys didn't know
Brainiac the Legion of super-heroes is
gonna be on Supergirl tonight in
Brainiac 5 half computer half organic
life-form all coluan and not to brag but
a 12th level intellect
my name is Coral docks but the
Legionnaires just called me brainy
Legionnaires did Monell send you yes yes
to make sure that your neural pathways
clear and intact your brain is in truly
remarkable health or someone languishing
in a coma
uh I'm sorry did you say coma mmm did I
bury the lead you've been in a coma for
two days I'm in my logs
oh you mean the physical manifestation
at the place in which your subconscious
feels most comfortable your dad loved
if I'm in a coma how are you here so for
the next couple of weeks
supergirl were ere episodes then on
February 12th legends of tomorrow is
taking their timeslot they're gonna do
their two-part Constantine episode then
we'll find out for sure whether or not
wally west is coming on legends because
if he's going anywhere i really do think
it's going to be legends and the
president of the network was teasing
people in an interview he did last week
where he said maybe wally will go on
legends you'll have to watch and find
out so the president of the network
wouldn't say something like that if it
weren't going to happen so we don't want
to say that it's confirmed but it does
sound like it's confirmed that wally is
going to legends but i'll post updates
as we get them don't worry they'll be
flashed tomorrow because everything's
back so like I said there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a comments on the video I'll name
a new winner when I post new DC so you
can click here to learn all about iron
spider may be showing up during Avengers
infinity war and you can click here to
learn all about Wolverine crossover
there was a bunch of Avengers stuff over
the weekend thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you